في تركيا الترقب هو سيد الموقف في السباق
الانتخابي الذي يعد الاهم في تاريخ البلاد
الحديث بعد مرور 20 عاما تقريبا هجود ضخمه
بالميادين يحاول من خلالها المرشحون
تحديدا اردوغان ومعارضه
استعراض كامل قوتهم والحصول على اكبر عدد
ممكن من الداعمين لسياسهم المختلفه في
اسطنبول مشاهدينا عقد مرشح تحالف الامه
المعارضه التجمع الرئيسي بمشاركه قاده
الاحزاب الخمسه الاخرى في التحالف في
الوقت نفسه مشاهدينا يواصل اردوغان عقد
تجمعات الانتخابيه حيث هاجم المعارضه
وداعا للمنافسه اللطيفه كما سماها كما عبر
عن سعادته بالحشد الكبير في قيصر الذي
تجاوز 135 الف شخص لكن ولاول مره وفق
مراقبين يواجه اردوغان احتمال خساره حتى
في طرابزون التي من المتوقع ان يتراجع
فيها الدعم له وفقه تقرير صادر عن السندي
تايمز حيث تشير استطلاعات الراي الى ان
نسبه كبيره من الاتراك الجدد دون سن
الخامسه والعشرين معرضون
بالمعارضون للنظام الذي ينتهجه اردوغان
نتابع من كل حدب وصوب في اسطنبول
والولايات المجاوره تداعى انصار الطاوله
السداسيه لدعم مرشحهم كمالك
في اكبر تجمع انتخابي للمعارضه عشرات
الالاف ضاق بهم ميدان مالطا في الشطر
الاسيوي باسطنبول الحق والحقوق والعداله
هو لسان حال انصار المعارضه وزعماء
الطاوله السداسيه الذين حضروا في هذا
التجمع
سيذهب اكثر من 800 الف شاب في اسطنبول
يصوتون لاول مره الى صناديق الاقتراع
سنستبدل الحكومه الاستبداديه بوسائل
ديمقراطيه
المعارضه بعدتها وعديدها ارادت تحدي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بحجم
الحشود والتجمعات الانتخابيه فاختارت
اسطنبول للمواجهه في رساله قويه بان فرص
مرشحها بالفوز كبيره هذه المره الانتخابات
تشهد منافسه شرسه بخلاف المرات السابقه في
الاسبوع الاخير ستحسم الكثير من الاصوات
خصوصا انه يشهد نشاطا كبيرا من السياسيين
ارى ان تحالف الامه متقدم بخطوه على
التحالف
وعود انتخابيه كثيره قدمها زعماء المعارضه
للناخبين في هذا التجمع لا سيما الوعود
الاقتصاديه وتوسيع مجال الحريات وحقوق
الانسان على ما يقولون
دائما للحريات والعداله والحقوق لذلك
ساصوت له اعتقد انه سيجلب السلامه لتركيا
لدي اعاقه جسديه منذ عام 2010 طلبت حزب
العداله والتنميه مرارا بتوفير فرصه عمل
لي لكن لم يستجيبوا لطلبي هذا التجمع
الضخم للمعارضه من المنتظر ان يقابله تجمع
ضخم اخر في اسطنبول يوم الاحد لكن هذه
المره لتحالف الشعب ومرشحه الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في
الايام الكبيره على حجر مؤيديه في
الميادين وتمثل اسطنبول اهم استعراض القوه
لمرشح المعارضه في مواجهه اردوغان زيدان
العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات